[Music]
my name is Austin Buckner and I have a
question about the multi-verse so if
there does exist an infinite amount of
universes then mathematically there's a
100 chance that there exists at least
one universe out there in the multiverse
that cannot support the idea of any
other universe existing except for that
one particular universe and my question
is doesn't this create a paradox in the
multi-universe idea Austin you are
asking a fabulous question about
multiverses the answer for me is clearly
I don't know this is to say is it just a
question of definition that there is one
universe and within it our sub vs. or
multiverses or is it actually everything
that we know and see and can detect is
nominally replicated at some other
dimension or some other space beyond
space that we are only able to imagine
and the only reason we think that they
might exist these multiverses beyond
space-time is because there's no reason
to exclude them like there's no reason
they couldn't exist
these are wonderful questions I've seen
many talks on this I've gone to symposia
about this and I don't know the answer
however we have the Spitzer Space
Telescope where we have Hubble Space
Telescope if we're going to have James
Webb Space Telescope and these
instruments along with ground-based
telescopes are peering farther and
farther into the past looking at light
that came from the Big Bang and the
unknowable time the Planck time getting
back that far and so what came before
that is that even a meaningful question
is it just our perception and the nature
of our perception of time that limits
our ability to understand what might be
beyond our universe or not these are
wonderful questions but here's also when
you get a chance support space
exploration because learning more about
the cosmos tells us more about ourselves
and tells us more about where we all
might have come
and then ultimately are we alone in all
this in the cosmos or in this universe
or beyond whoa it's a great question
[Music]